first i want to say congratulations on
this movie thank you and i sincerely
cannot wait to see it again next time in
imax i cannot wait um but i want to go
backwards actually if you don't mind
when when you guys were making get out
you the movie is made for like four
something million dollars it was like
not
expected to do what it did i don't think
when did you realize oh wait this is
like people love this and this is gonna
be pretty big i i know because i was in
it i couldn't have that realization when
everyone else had that realization so i
remember i had that realization when we
did a q a
in
january the year after it came out
and
it was packed
and i was like this has been out free
this isn't enough for nearly a year
why is this room packed
and i was like oh
[Music]
it's a banger
okay cool all right cool and then i
understood that it was it had a life way
beyond
a normal film life you know so which is
like he goes and then you watch it's on
tv and then you go i'll watch it it
would get out as a completely different
it's an anomaly in that sense jumping
into nope um when jordan told you about
it did he is it like a text message do
you want to do another movie with me how
exactly does that work no he just goes
yeah i'm gonna talk to you i was like
yeah are you up
and then um
then uh we sat down and he called no we
sat down about something else and then
he called me about it
uh
and then we had a two-hour conversation
he spoke the whole film he like just
said the whole film to me over the phone
and the pandemic
and then uh i was like oh that's a lot
to take in let's look you know like
you've written that down
you write the script and then um yeah he
wrote it down and then we read it and
then we just kept building and
conversating like that so that's how i
came to it i'm just so curious about how
he's changed as a filmmaker because he's
three for three he's he's a very gifted
artist um i'm just curious what it's
like
what did he change at all when he was
making this film in terms of is he
exactly the same on set with the way he
directs you i mean like has anything
changed through his experience yeah i
think he's he's way more assured um way
um
and he just believes in his instinct
more and he always has believed in it
which is i think why get out popped and
why us is
is still in a conversation so it's like
um but with
with um
nope he just believed and then said
everyone then believed more with him you
know and i can see and he's just you
know he's on it he's on it but it's a
completely different experience because
it was like
get out was so contained about it's this
is contained but contained in an open
expansive way as opposed to containment
in that closed way
and um so he uh yeah he but a lot stayed
the same in jordan he's a lot of that's
what makes him a great filmmaker he
always had uh i'm a big fan of hoyt and
he was your cinematographer um and you
guys got to film with imax cameras i'm
just curious if you could was it was
this your first time working with like
the real imax cameras and and what was
that experience like for you it was
quite tough like because you couldn't
hear it was so loud you couldn't really
hear
what the note or like sometimes john
will talk to you through the scene
because a lot has happened in cgi ways
and then like you couldn't hear it or
you couldn't hear the other person in it
and then um
but it does feel like wow like we're
doing this big i still haven't really
processed the imacs of it all i really
want to see it on imac yeah the thing
about it that people don't realize is
imax cameras are uh loud they're not
silent it's not like you're filming with
digital did you feel any extra pressure
as an actor because when you're shooting
with imax film you know the film's going
you know it's expensive did you feel any
additional pressure when you're using
cameras like that or did it not affect
you nah cause it's just like cinemas
forever so you can't really
stay in a moment just gotta give all
that you can and then i just i don't
i'm i in my head if i'm in character i'm
not making a film
i understand i'm making a film but if
i'm in the mind frame of the person i'm
i'm not making a film i'm living a life
so then i'm like well
that's what he would do in his life so
there's an imax there you're capturing
it but i'm living a life it's like
there's a line
right there how have you actually been
describing the film to friends and
family i haven't been it's hard to
describe but i had the same thing with
get out i couldn't i didn't describe it
so no one really knew what it was about
when it came out like that what you've
done and so i think the same thing with
this i told him like the region in the
area but it's hard to describe it's hard
it's to be experienced a hundred percent
um i am a big fan of your work thank you
and i'm very curious i love talking to
actors about like how they prepare for a
big scene so hypothetically speaking you
have a huge scene on a monday you know
it's emotional or it's going to take
something out of you
how early on are you getting ready for
that scene can you take me through your
process a little bit is there a lot are
there a lot of lines in the scene well
we could play it two different ways one
there's a lot of lines or two it's
really emotional uh i'll give you both
uh a lot of lines i would learn it a
week before like the black mirror thing
i did this whole speech it was like six
pages of dialogue or whatever i had to a
week before i would just chip away chip
away at it because it'd just be on my
mind because it's on the screen like
that's hap that's gonna happen and then
if it's really emotional i don't really
do preparing beforehand i would prepare
like read the script
and go okay cool and make certain
decisions and make realizations but i
like the immediacy of the moment i like
doing things that feel like the last
edition you know like like a newspaper
like this is the last thought i had in
this time before i went to the edit so
yeah i would
let it be spontaneous you've done a
number of different projects which do
you think what was the one that really
stressed you out or made you really
think how am i going to do this scene
was there one in particular that you
still remember as like a real challenge
like how am i going to do it or just you
know like one that really got in your
brain in terms of
i don't know being nervous about it
maybe
the iron revolutionary scene was a
was a very in judaism black messiah that
was a very um
man what is going to happen
and i think i did the queen in stem
press tour just before that day so i had
a week of being off and i was in press
mode so i wasn't even in it and i was
like ah there's something happening
there that i'm about to do that was a
really thing and also the fact that his
son was on set
um was a big emotional one so that was
the one i was like that's going to be an
intense day yeah i love talking about
deleted scenes do you remember any for
this film yeah there was a couple that
was beautiful i mean i love like
beautiful like like shots of like
amazing look at this location you shoot
it i mean it's like cinema yeah and
there was an amazing well i was just
riding by myself in a it's an atv right
you call it like atv riding and it was a
super wide shot like of just seeing the
whole ranch and the scale of it i
thought that seemed that shot was so
amazing i i i i i don't think it's there
anymore well last time i saw it i don't
think it was there but yeah that that
was an amazing shot that i missed i love
learning about the behind the scenes of
the making of movies and shows for soon
to be fans of nope is there anything you
think might surprise them to learn about
like the actual making of the movie
you could see
jupiter's claim from hayward
ranch
like you could like that's what like it
was like you could see the set
from in the distance it was that like we
just took over this whole area
essentially and it was like but it was
like
five miles away or six miles away you
can see the other set and then you can
see
hayward ranch from jupiter's claim so
that's pretty cool
um what else is there
i mean there's so much that happened man
so much what other things are over
behind the scenes what areas are you
thinking well i don't know it's like
sometimes um i mean it opens the door to
so many different conversations in terms
of like there was a day on set where
everything completely changed and jordan
did this or oh it was the day that me
and jordan had a heat stroke oh for real
yeah i was telling him that there yeah
oh yeah like uh and i was like i was
sitting there i had that orange hoodie
in the middle of summer in the desert
and i was sitting there and i'm like
yeah and i'm like the doctor came in
he's like all right i don't know i feel
a bit like i can't i want to move but my
body's saying no he said you're going
for a heat stroke and then jordan was
going through that exact same time in
another vehicle so i was like and then
we had to like stop the shoot
in order for us to like get our
strengths back to go back to set see
that that fills in with a good that
that's a nice story listen i already got
a wrap i'm just gonna say sincerely man
uh thank you so much for your work and
for giving me your time thank you i
appreciate that man felix much